a good part of my sanity rests on the
belief that there is a just God and if
there was a just God there's an
afterlife welcome to the sunday special
with Dennis Prager who's stopping by
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at zip recruiter so hiring
is challenging there's one place you can
go we're hiring is simple fast and smart
it's a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates and that
place is zip recruiters comm slash been
guests because I have a guest
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards they
don't stop there
have powerful matching technology and
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job
and then as the applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spots lights
the top candidates he never missed a
great match the procurer is really
effective so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter at a
quality candidate through the site
within the first day and with results
like that it is no wonder zip recruiter
is the highest rating higher in site in
the United States right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash been guest go try it for free we
use it here at the daily wire offices if
the char doesn't go well today we'll be
using it again to replace employees it's
just that simple
zip recruit calm slash been guest be e
and gue est zip recruiter comm slash
been guest zip recruiter is the smartest
way to hire Dennis Prager welcome to the
Ben Shapiro Sunday special thanks for
coming by
it's just great to be here I'm really
excited to talk Bible with you because
we have to bring some holiness back to
the set last week we had Sam Harris and
his blasphemy on the set so now we get
to have video to do exactly Dennis
Prager and his godly views on the said
today Dennis obviously if you haven't
been watching the news you haven't
followed the Amazon charts as the author
of the bestseller the rationale Bible
the book of Exodus so he's gonna do all
five volumes of the of the Old Testament
the books of Moses and he's done Exodus
it was a huge bestseller sold tens of
thousands of copies as number one in the
nonfiction list on amazon.com which has
to be really gratifying since you've
written a bunch of best-selling books
but this one is actually a Bible
commentary so let's start from beginning
what actually made you think hey I'll
write a Bible commentary and then just
release that out into the world well the
interesting among the interesting things
is and it's great to be with you been
among the interesting things is that
of all the books I wrote this is the one
I least expected to be a best-seller
this was written 100% out of idealism
they're all idealistic books but but
there was a hope and in some of them
were bestsellers but this has been the
best-selling book I ever wrote and it's
the last one I expect that I wrote a
book on happiness on American values I
mean some good stuff but what whatever
credit I get I think 50% of the reason
is that there is a thirst for exactly
that namely I want I'd like to actually
know what the Bible has to say I want it
to be rational which is my entire
approach and there's a thirst that look
this is the most biblically illiterate
generation in American history as you
know as well as anyone the average
American home throughout American
history if it had one book it had the
Bible they read it to their kids every
night this was the source of wisdom what
is iíve asked callers on 33 years of
radio said I'd like to know if it's not
the Bible just name a book that is the
source of wisdom for you and it's
fascinating you know what people say if
they don't have this uh life experience
let me go
yeah but then everybody has to reinvent
the wheel do you mean there's nothing
that precedes you that had more wisdom
than maybe you do anyway I know it's the
wisest book I am convinced of it and
making it rational verse by verse it's
been my life's task I know the Hebrew
real well I don't as you do and you know
it you grit there are wonderful
commentaries that don't by people who
don't know Hebrew but I think to really
do it right you have to know the Hebrew
so let's let's start from the very
beginning of the the basis for the
rationale Bible because I think that you
can make a really solid argument that
the ethics that the Bible promotes the
ethical monotheism that you promote this
is based on on a certain level of human
rationality in a little while I want to
talk about human rationality versus
God's rationality will do the rib for a
problem which stands above which but
let's start with the basis of Revelation
so when you say that the Bible is
rational do you mean that Revelation
itself can be rationalized that it is
rational that a voice came down from the
top of a mountain and then
to give a bunch of laws to a do to his
staff so you got to go step by step is
it rational to believe that there's a
creator I think as the late Charles
Krauthammer said when I asked him I cuz
I never asked him about politics I
figured everybody could hear him on
politics but so I asked him about other
things and I asked him he was in he was
a totally secular man so said what do
you think of atheism and I thought he'd
said well and maybe so I I don't know he
said he said that's the most foolish of
all possible possibilities said it's
absurd I mean he was he dumped on
atheism more than I have so to me that
there's a creator is purely rational so
then the that's purely rational this
didn't come out by itself this world
this universe
you mean buck it just didn't happen by
chance
okay then any point of faith or is there
a rational no no that's purely rational
I'll tell you where faith comes in that
God is good there's so much bad in the
world
that I admit there's a leap of faith to
believing that the Creator is good it's
no leap of faith to a creator I believe
there's a leap of faith to God is good
but once you've made that leap that God
is good which I think is somewhat
rational after all why would a bad
creator make it make a person capable of
being good it's a bizarre sort of
situation so if the Creator cares how we
live then the Creator will give us
guidelines those guidelines are in the
Bible that's how I look at it okay so
let's define good so when you say that
God is good what do you mean by God is
good because obviously you don't mean
God is good by human moral standards
because then that would put us that is
the rip throw a problem right that puts
us above God is God living up to our
standards and if so why do we need God
morality because there's a mixture of
God's standards and our standards
otherwise we can't understand anything
if it's purely divine then we can't
understand it when Abraham the first
monotheists the first Jew argues with
God which by the way is one of the
reasons I'm in love with these first
five books what what is called the Torah
I mean I and I mean it I'm in love with
those books ever since I was a kid and
I'm not the most traditional guy but
that I fell in love with and I love the
idea that you can argue with God I tell
I tell Chris
all the time that's largely another huge
Christian audience and I am a Jew and I
am I explain
don't forget Israel God's people has a
meaning it means argue with or struggle
with God and a lot of Christians forgot
that and a lot and you know and
secularists don't even know that there's
something beautiful about that let me
can I consider a quick anecdote a Muslim
woman called my radio show many years
ago when I was just on in LA and she
said Dennis I know you we could ask you
anything I said that's right well I'm a
Muslim woman and I'd like to know why
aren't you a Muslim and I was right old
her I want you to know I am complimented
by the fact that you would even ask it
means you think I've given this theory a
serious thought and I have so I said to
her here's my answer
Islam in Arabic means submit to God
Israel in Hebrew means struggle with God
I rather struggle with God
than submit to God there was a moment of
silence and she said good answer and
hung up she knew as a Muslim I was right
that is a huge difference so that so the
fact that we can argue with God means
that we can perceive God's morality so
when I say God is good it is both in his
terms
am i believe our terms so when it comes
to that standard of good there there are
two main sources in Western civilization
for the standard of good one is the
Bible did you do Christian tradition and
the other is this idea of natural law
these see reflected a lot in the
founding philosophy it's it's reflected
as well in into mystic thought this idea
that you can look at the universe and
you can discern from the universe that
there are certain things that are true
and certain things that are false so for
example you're an advocate for
traditional marriage and the natural law
of view of marriage would be exactly
this that God created man and woman to
be together and the proof of this that
they are capable of producing children
so what when we're trying to discern the
good do we need revelation or natural
all alone suffice and or are they
mirrors of one another or is natural law
itself irrelevant so there are two
questions there
do we need God pregnant
eclis do we need God philosophically
you're asking philosophically I'm more
concerned with the pragmatic because
that's how we live right we we practice
we live but I look clearly if we needed
revelation from the beginning God would
have revealed the Torah as it were or
the Ten Commandments to Adam and Eve so
clearly God believes it's possible to be
good without his direct revelation
otherwise it's not fair to have blamed
came for killing Abel right Cain could
have said hey hello you didn't give me
any rules what the hell am I supposed to
know but he didn't say that so yes
there's clearly an embedded conscience I
do believe that the problem is it
doesn't work well and so I always say
the Ten Commandments are God's third
attempt at trying to start trying to get
us to be good people and and and
choosing a people to be to embody
holiness and goodness which was the what
is known is Israelite and then
ultimately doing so that's that's that
then there's the pragmatic question
that's the more the one I strike and not
struggle with but that's the one I
advocate more I begin my introduction
which and enough itself is a booklet
because I introduction is very important
what I'm trying to do and whom are
trying to appeal to and I begin with a
very revealing part of my own life
like many people in my late teens and
early 20s and even early teens I had
difficulties with my parents what what
else is new right but I always honored
them always from the day I left my
parents home at 21 till they died my
father at 96 my mother at 89 I called
them every single week I it didn't
matter where I was on earth and the
reason was one because I believe God
instructed me honor your father and
mother and when I tell people who say oh
I don't need God to be good really then
how come so many adult kids who are
angry at their parents don't don't call
them every week believe me we can all
use a commander in heaven to tell us
what to do so when it comes to that
back to the philosophical question for
one second so to play skeptic since
you're rational Bible guy so what took
God so long why'd he need three attempts
why does he wait until the the
revelation at Sinai great question and I
I have dealt with that in my in my mind
my whole life to show us why it was
necessary that's why to show us hey
hello conscience alone doesn't work look
at how bad man got because otherwise if
if God had given the Ten Commandments
the the Bible the Torah or whatever in
the beginning was who needs it
conscience would be enough but
conscience failed and we ended up with
the world of Noah which God destroyed
and by the way I defend Noah that
Genesis is coming up I do defend God God
wants us to be good and if everybody's
bad he's gonna start again
I haven't debate with my wife you're
gonna love this my wife thinks he
shouldn't have saved Noah my wife thinks
the world is so screwed up that it was
very dark she is as light as the Sun in
personality but a herd view of Linda
call that one I know you would exactly
so so with all of that said I you know
to her for a lot of folks who read the
Bible they don't know a lot about the
Bible and maybe their first experience
with reading the Bible is gonna be
reading your book when you read the text
of the Bible there's a lot in there that
unquestionably is brutal and that seems
to our modern sensibilities just bizarre
it's it seemed the Bible contemplating
witchcraft for example or the Bible or
the Bible endorsing quasi slavery this
is an argument that Sam Harris gave me
last week as he was saying well you know
this book this book you could do better
than this book today like if you just
remove certain sections from this book
and they would automatically make it
better so what's all this stuff in the
Bible about all right first of all since
the by first volume is about Exodus I
have an enormous amount on the slavery
issue right the first thing to be said
is there's very little slavery what it
what is what what the laws are about is
essentially a bonded indenture which by
the way is the way so many people came
to America people don't know that but a
vast number of the white people who came
to the United States came as indentured
servants they've got no pay they started
out
life working for somebody for no pay
which you can call a slave if you wish
but they didn't and by the way as I know
you know the word and Hebrew for slave
is also the word for servant it's an and
I wish I wish there had been a
distinction in Hebrew because Moses is
called and an airbed of God that's the
word and and is Moses a slave of God
nobody assumes that so it's not at all
always slave it is but if you look at
although first you cannot return an
escaped slave that's a law in the taurah
a law there in exodus you if something
that was immediately a statement of hey
you mistreat your slave and they escaped
you're not getting your slave back you
kill your slave you get killed i mean
your slave has to has to have a day off
with you on the sabbath every week I
mean this is major stuff why didn't it
just say no slavery because it wants the
world to be better it's not the Torah is
not preoccupied and I'm using the word
Torah cuz this is about the vows five
books about it but my commentary is for
people of every faith in no faith but if
there is a realization that you can't
ban all bad immediately maybe the Torah
wanted us to be vegetarian so a hundred
years from now and I think most people
will be vegetarian people will sit like
a Sam Harris and say well why don't it
ban meat-eating
instead it humanized meat-eating it
moralized it that's what it did to
whatever slavery it had it humanized it
because you can make the world better
much more so through evolution than
revolution okay so in just a second I
want to ask you about the religious
objections to applying rationality to
the Bible because so far we've dealt
with sort of the rationalist objections
to the Bible itself and then I want to
come at it from the right as opposed to
from the left but first let's talk about
your death because it's gonna happen 71%
of people say they need life insurance
only 59% have coverage which means at
least 12% of people are procrastinating
the truth is you all need life insurance
cuz y'all gonna die sorry to break it to
you and that means you don't have as
much time as you think you do
procrastinating is normally a bad thing
but if you've been avoiding getting life
insurance procrastinating may actually
have worked in your favor because while
you're putting it off policy genius was
making it easy policy genius is the easy
to compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes when
it's that easy
putting it off becomes a lot harder you
can compare quotes while sitting on the
couch watching TV you can compare quotes
while listening to this podcast just go
try it policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance it's
placed over 20 billion dollars in
coverage and they don't just make life
insurance easy they also compare
disability insurance and renter's
insurance and health insurance so if you
care about it they can cover it if you
need life insurance you've been putting
it off because it's too confusing or you
don't have the time checkout policy
genius the easy way to compare top
insurers and find the best value for you
no sales pressure zero hassle it's free
policy genius com when it's this easy to
compare life insurance there's no reason
to put it off go check it out a policy
genius com okay so by the way I just
want to add on your behalf that I tell
my listeners that life insurance is a
moral obligation well that's perfect so
policy genius life insurance is a moral
obligation Dennis Prager said so you can
take it to the bank so let's talk about
the the sort of skepticism of applying
reason to the Bible from the right so so
far we've talked about you know people
on sort of the secular left or just
secularism in general who would be
skeptical about the Bible itself there
are a lot of folks in the religious
community of the play the community I
grew up in the community you grew up in
who would say that attempts to apply
rationality to the Mitzvah to the the
commandments of the Torah is actually
counterproductive because now you're
placing man above God and what you are
doing is infusing a need you're implying
that God needs man in a way that that is
not true that God gives a certain level
of commandment and now we're trying to
reason around it but as soon as we start
using our reason reason also is is a
universal acid to a certain extent you
can reason your way to anything so if
you start off with a commandment here
and you say okay well take for example
slavery and we say okay well we've
reasoned our way to slavery is bad using
the beginning point of the of the Bible
why couldn't we reason our way to
something else why couldn't we reason
our way to slavery is universally good
based on the Bible because reason
doesn't have a lot of limits to it so
what rules of Reason ought we apply that
will prevent the destruction of the
rules themselves so if you think that
the mitzvot are important if you think
the commandments are important then
either you know which ones don't well
let me explain on a personal note my
vehicle to God is his reason I don't
have a great
bond with God - I wish I did I don't my
vehicle to God is reason my vehicle to
faith is reason my vehicle through
religious life is reason so I can't I
can't be what I'm not that that if
someone doesn't care about reason then
they they won't find my book interesting
but we live in an age where almost
everything has to be rationally
explained I like that fact I think it's
good and there was a book written when I
was a kid called we have reason to
believe by by an English rabbi Louis
Jacobs and it's it's it I I'm
embarrassed to say I didn't read the
whole book and I but I am equally
embarrassed but I will tell you the
truth the title changed my life the
title I can't say that about any other
book it was a brilliant double entendre
we have reason to believe the obvious is
there are reasons to believe but the the
the secondary meaning was we have been
given reason in order to believe and
that is what I felt at 20 and I feel
today that reason is my vehicle so let
me give you a personally good example
there is a law in in the Torah that says
if you have a particularly unruly child
a terrible son you take him to the court
and if they find him guilty they stone
him to death and people use that as a
great example of how primitive the the
Bible is though the Torah specifically I
used reason to realize wait a minute way
way way way wait that law is was a moral
genius that was the first law in human
history to take away a parent's right to
kill their child that's what the law did
no child was ever killed in Jewish
history by a court but what they did was
what the Torah did was parents you're
still in charge but wait a minute you
can't kill your child only a court can
so what it did was it maintained
parental authority but took away
forever their right to kill their child
so it was a staggering moral advance I
show that with every difficult law in
the Torah okay so how do you tell which
are the moral advances that we need to
move beyond and which are the moral
advances that's as far as we go so to
take an example you suggest that let's
use the one you just used just to take
the counterpoint so your your argument
is that this is a movement away from
parents being able to kill their
children willy-nilly and so you have a
court process that's put in place
specifically to prevent all of this so
the goal of the commandment is to
prevent the fulfillment of the
commandment to a certain extent so now
take the commandment with regard to the
one that's popular today with regard to
homosexuality for example how do we know
that that wasn't just a progressive
attempt to move away from something
worse but the really progressive thing
would be to say that what it's really
talking about is we're moving toward
monogamy for male couples or female
couples which is the way that some
people in in sort of liberal
congregations try to reinterpret that
phrase in other words where does reason
stop and we say okay we've gone far
enough and where do we say okay well
this commandment was written for the
time and it was determined to drag
people out of a certain level of
primitivism and now we can drag them
even further out of that level of
primitivism I am that's in the third
book of the Bible Leviticus I devote
20,000 words to that verse and this is
the gist of it the gist is this I
thought before I did my research and I'm
sure everyone thinks this that the Bible
simply
codified what every other society
believed and that is homosexuality is
bad end of issue it turns out and I
learned this from from homosexual
scholars and pro homosexual Pro gay
scholars I this is not from me every
society in the world except for biblical
Society said that homosexuality was good
this was a total revelation ancient
China ancient Incas ancient Egyptians
ancient Greeks you anywhere on earth I
read a book by a Harvard professor and
you know
is not my favorite reading I'm and it's
not only because it's it's very it's
very involved obviously on ancient
Chinese homosexuality so this was the
rule like in ancient Greece women were
for babies boys were for fun
the Torah did set it the opposite the
Torah said wives are for fun the Torah
in that law Hirata sized marriage it was
a staggering revolution in human history
so I even even accepting your logic that
let's let's take the laws of Sabbath to
take a less controversial example so
there are certain laws of Sabbath that
have been stricken made strict over time
right that we you and I disagree on the
interpretation of Sabbath for example
you know you'll you'll drive on
Saturdays I won't drive on Saturdays
because there's a rabbinic tradition
that you don't drive on Saturdays so
right by the way I don't drive just I
wouldn't drive through a ballgame I
don't dropping I Drive to a Sabbath
exactly okay right now yeah I don't want
to miss all right so right but the
question is at least from the Orthodox
point of view or from a fundamentalist
point of view so how does orthodoxy not
slip into reconstruction ISM or into
reform so which which was you get to
abrogate and which laws do not get that
well for one thing I I don't think we
can change torah law torah law I believe
the Torah is ultimately from God whether
it was all given at one time or not even
the rabbi's themselves differed on on
when exactly was it through prophets was
it later was it doesn't matter to me who
wrote it is it more important to me than
how it was written I believe it's a
divine document that is if I didn't I
would never have spent this time and I
wouldn't take it seriously I believe it
is a divine document so I don't believe
that that not using spark plugs is
divine I will acknowledge that it is
rabbinic if you're asking me from an
Orthodox Jewish perspective and by the
way Orthodox Jews love the commentary as
they should
yeah it brings people to great faith and
I want that but it is true that I think
rabbinic law can change I do believe
that as for Torah law for example I
don't smoke my
or a cigar which I do every day of the
week I don't do it on on Shabbat because
it says do not burn a fire on the
Sabbath so I just want to make that
clear I take this stuff very seriously
and by the way I show you would let
you'll love this I show and it took a
lot of research why it why is fire the
aside from the guy who what is because
she hates even be the guy who picks up
the sticks on see ya well a big one
little sticks or whatever it is
si fer the the the issue is only fire
why it is fire what's the big deal on
fire on the Sabbath fire is the only
thing outside of making a baby that we
do ex nihilo and so fire represents
creation and the Sabbath's purpose is to
not create to imitate God and rest and
not create one day a week so and my
proof is you are not banned from fire on
the Jewish holy days other than the
Sabbath that became a rabbinic law later
we but in the Torah itself only on the
Sabbath because the the holy days
Passover Tabernacles and and Pentecost
Shavuot Sukkot and Pesa do not represent
creation but this does anyway this
sounds a lot of trend of alluded I'm
sure to a lot of work or at least
complex it's not I make things very
clear but yes III admit that there are
laws that you know III believe that a
that a dish that has been put in boiling
water has effectively gotten rid of its
prior of foods and can be eaten from but
you know look I know that the Orthodox
within jewelry the Orthodox are my
allies I know that and by the way the
Orthodox invited me to speak knowing
that I'm not Orthodox to their great
credit every year Passover for its
that's right that's a perfect exactly so
let's talk about why so why the Bible um
so what is the proof that the Bible is
the best moral system as opposed to
other divinely ordained moral systems
how do you how do you make that judgment
because you're not
a comparative theologian per se you
don't mean you spend time reading about
other religion but oh yes from what I
understand you don't consider yourself
an expert on on various other religion
so why why this religion in particular
the obvious answer is the fruit the
United States of America was not founded
only by Orthodox Christians in other
words not every founder believed in the
Trinity but every founder believed that
the Bible was the greatest book ever
written including Jefferson and Franklin
and and Lincoln it's the one book he had
a midden go to church much but he had
the book this the there are people who
believed in the Bible who did a lot of
evil there's no question about that but
people did evil everywhere so the only
question mature people ask is not why
was there evil anywhere it's why was
there good anywhere it's not like why
was there poverty that's the norm why is
there any affluence that's the only
question that intelligent people should
ask and the answer is capitalism
capitalism is the only thing that
creates after once the Bible was the
only thing that created moral society so
when it comes to when it comes to God
you've made the argument that you can be
a moral person without God is an
individual poor you can't build a moral
system without God so so can you explain
that a little bit for people who have
yes of course you know look there are
good people who believe in anything
there were good people who believed in
Zeus but nobody would argue that Zeus
made good people that that's the point
of course there are good people who
believe in nothing they believe in
anything of course that's true and there
are bad people who believe in God I say
that every time
and yet all over the internet you will
find Prager says that you can't be good
if you don't believe in God and I've
never said it in my life I'd have to be
stupid to say it there were good
atheists how many times can I say it the
answer is there's no limit because they
don't want to hear it but you can't
build a good Society without God you can
have good individuals we care you care I
care all of us should care about what
kind of society we make this country
there's a reason there's a map there are
three mottos a pluribus unum
Liberty and In God We Trust okay that's
pretty important with with that and and
Franklin did not believe we could have a
good society without God Franklin's in
autobiography his theology and I just
read Thomas kids book on Franklin's
theology just to make sure he's
identical to mine identical God exists
God will judge all of us that's what I
believe that's what Franklin believed
and Franklin is called so called deist
theist is not what people think theist
means these most people think is like
Aristotle the unmoved mover a creator
and then the creator went to sleep or
retired to another universe that is not
what they were they believe they simply
weren't Orthodox small o in their
Christianity but they believed in
Providence in the God who judges and
that God had a role in the founding of
America ok so I want to talk in a minute
with you about death because we've
talked a lot about sort of the
life-affirming qualities of rationality
and the Torah first however let's talk
about your online privacy so with all
the recent news about online security
breaches it's hard not to worry about
where my data goes making an online
purchase simply accessing your email it
could put your private information at
risk you are being tracked online by
social media sites marketing companies
your mobile internet providers how they
make their money not only can they
record your browsing history they often
sell it to other corporations who want
to profit from that information which is
why I've taken back my privacy using
expressvpn expressvpn has easy-to-use
apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
only takes one click and expressvpn
secures and and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data hiding
your public IP address protecting
yourself with express you can across
less than seven bucks a month it's
really cheap and its really useful
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar everybody should
have a VPN it comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if your if you
ever want to use public Wi-Fi and you
want to keep hackers and spies from
seeing your data expressvpn is the
solution if you don't want to hand over
your online history to your internet
provider or data resellers that's what
expressvpn is for protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free and expressvpn
comm / pen that's expr ESS VPN comm /
pen for three months free with 1-year
package that's expressvpn comm / Ben to
learn more okay so
Dennis's talk
little bit about the afterlife in the
Bible because you mentioned the idea of
God judging and and II and the notion
that after we die God basically decides
whether we were good or bad the the
Torah doesn't have a lot about the
afterlife actually the five books of
Moses are pretty vague on on exactly
what happens when you die there there
are a few sort of vague references or
allusions to it the idea that you know
God kisses Moses and and Moses go
somewhere but you're not really sure
where and the there's obviously in
various different theologies whole
worlds built up around what happens
after we die so number one what do you
believe about what happens after we die
number two where does that come from in
the Bible and number three do you
actually need to believe in the
afterlife in order to be good okay so
one at a time one of the 850 reasons I'm
in love with the Torah I said I'm not in
love with God I admit it I wish I were
as I've written actually an essay that
the hardest the law and the Torah is to
love God with all your heart but with
all the suffering in the world I I admit
it I find it I find it hard not I hope
I'll achieve it one day but I do love
the Torah ironically I really I'm in
love with it I admit it and one of the
things I'm in love of is its reticence
to talk about much about the afterlife
because life is so hard and has been for
the vast majority of people it's very
easy to focus on the afterlife and
ignore this world God wants us to make
this world heavenly not heaven that's
not possible and not to think about
heaven all that much however I will tell
you there is no doubt in my mind that
the Torah believes in the afterlife and
I will give you two proofs one is that
about of six people it says when they
died they they were gathered unto their
people or their kin four of the six
people it says it about
we're not buried with kin or family four
of the six so being gathered to their
kin cannot possibly be about where
they're buried secondly it says
before they were ever buried so the act
of dying itself means you are gathered
to your kin I don't know any other read
other than you there there was a soul
that gathers with with those that
preceded you there is no other I think
fair read to that verse number two is
not my argument it's Richard Elliot
Friedman who's not an Orthodox Jew but
he is a but he is also a very serious
scholar of the Bible world his own
commentary and he made this this the
following argument I believe was in an
email to me
I'm not know if he actually wrote it up
he might have and and he said given that
the Torah is so preoccupied with
rejecting ancient Egypt Egypt's values
because that's where the Hebrews grew up
right in ancient Egypt and it's you know
like all the plagues but one are against
the gods of Egypt so it's all a
rejection of ancient Egypt but he said
the biggest belief in ancient Egypt was
the afterlife the Torah could have
easily just said reject everything about
Egypt including the belief in an
afterlife but it said nothing the
biggest belief in Egypt is not
contradicted in the Torah so that's a
second reason it is clear the Torah
believes in it but it doesn't want us to
be preoccupied with the afterlife
the guys who believe they're going to
get 72 virgins for blowing innocent
people up are preoccupied with the
afterlife
okay the Torah is afraid of that and for
good reason now you asked another a part
the part three on that one right is that
okay okay good so part three is do we
have to believe in an afterlife to be
good people or they say there's a good
moral system well I would put it this
way without belief in an afterlife it
would be so obvious to me that God was
not good that I would disregard anything
that I thought this God said I would if
I didn't believe in an afterlife I'd be
an atheist because if God is good
there's an afterlife I mean because it's
so obvious torturers go have the same
oblivion as their tortured mother Teresa
goes the same places Adolf Hitler what
kind of crappy world is
this deity make I don't want anything to
do with him I rest my my whole case for
a belief and and for sanity on the
afterlife I admitted I fully admitted
that I their item for those interested
there's a five minute preview video on
the afterlife which I happened to give I
don't get most of the preview videos but
I you give I give good people give and
and there's a five minute case for just
for the afterlife but I I fully admit it
and I know I'm mocked for this I don't
give a damn but I mocked for it a good
part of my sanity rests on the belief
that there is a just God and if there
was a just God there's an afterlife okay
so let's talk about where the United
States seemingly has gone wrong in all
of this because we become a
significantly less religious people if
you go back to the 1950s the vast
majority of Americans were going to
church on a regular basis if you look at
the United States now that is that it's
just not the case anymore the the
religious numbers particularly among
people my age have declined markedly
it's a much more secular country what
happened why is it that religion seems
to have lost its it's sort of appeal
maybe it's coming back and we'll talk
about that in a second we'll talk about
whether you're a pessimist in a second
but what happened in the 1950s 60s 40s
why exactly was it that this religious
worldview that gave birth to the
greatest country in the history of the
world decide people just decided to toss
it overboard because the the generation
that's called the greatest generation
the world war ii generation which was a
great generation greatest or not they
were great they made one horrible
mistake they didn't teach their kids
what made America tick and part of it
was the Bible they they were so
preoccupied with making sure their kids
didn't have a depression I don't mean
psychological depression I mean economic
depression and that they wouldn't know
war that's all they wanted peace and
prosperity that's all that generation
ended up caring about so they taught
their kids nothing about America and
nothing about God and the Bible and the
results are the chaos that we see today
where teachers can't even call their
kids boys and girls because of this true
the ultimate arash
of denying that there was male and
female in the human species by the way I
will say this I wrote an essay many
years ago it's on the internet how I
found God in Colombia then I went back
to Colombia and gave this speech and I I
mean it sincerely seeing the moral
idiocy that pervades the universities
which are clearly the dumbest of our
institutions I believe that literally
I'm I wish I could I I didn't believe it
they are also the the most godless
institutions in Western civilization
Columbia where I learned nonsense in
graduate school Columbia made me realize
the genius of a line that you know well
wisdom begins with fear of God and that
changed my life one day walking through
Columbia I remember I asked myself why
am i learning that men and women are not
basically different that they're
basically the same this is ridiculous
how am i learning I was at the School of
International Affairs how am i learning
that the US and the Soviet Union were
moral equivalence that's what I was
being taught that they were just two
superpowers struggling it out it wasn't
a battle between liberty and and and
evil it was it was a battle between two
superpowers and then I realized oh my
god there's no wisdom at Columbia cuz
there's no God of Columbia I got to
believe in God thanks to the
irrationality of secularism so how do we
restore any sort of biblical value is
there a way to draw people back to it I
think there is a you know I've seen my
own life I think there are people who
are in search of something eternal and
meaningful because they're looking
around the system being presented by
what is left of our of our moral
leadership and saying this is a shambles
and they're looking for something that
actually has some eternal value to it
are you optimistic or pessimistic that's
going to happen and how is the best way
for religious leaders have an impact and
in driving that I'm not optimistic and
I'm not pessimistic I wish I could say
I'm optimistic but there was a I was in
a major discussion a dialogue years ago
with a great Catholic thinker and a
great Protestant thinker and I was the
Jew
not saying I'm a great thinker but I do
and one of them made a very powerful
point the Catholic actually is Robert
Novak who just passed the way he was and
and and he was great and he and he said
a very important thing he said Dennis
and I are the pessimists because I'm
from Eastern Europe and he's a Jew we
know how bad things can get the
Protestant god bless him doesn't know
how bad things can get and I've told
this to Protestant audiences frequently
and they they have agreed that they they
never looked at it that way I didn't
look at it that way the Robert Novak
brought it to my attention so I I'm not
optimistic and I'm not pessimistic I can
only say that a big part of the failure
is religious people they did not make
the case for the moral and an
intellectual necessity of religion they
relied on a lot of cliches they're nice
people but they they didn't know what to
do that's the reason I feel so committed
to this five-volume work and and the
fact that it is a big bestseller
I guess believe it or not not personally
but it gives me some reason for optimism
III don't know the answer but I know I
know we have to get the message out this
is the best thing going and America will
die and the West will die without this
so dennis has a bunch of things that you
do obviously you know Bible you have
Prager you which has reached hundreds of
millions of people at this point with
with your vit with your various videos
you have your radio show as well a lot
of what you do is politically driven
it's not just values driven it's it's
politically driven as well so how do you
how do you merge
how do values play into its politics how
much of your of your politics is driven
by biblical concern as a true person so
is it but a person and yet you're not a
theocratic that's correct so not at all
I that's the founders of this country of
the United States of America were giants
they came up with a line that is so
awesome God wants us to be free they
merged liberty and God most religious
life Christian or or any or or or
or any other did not merge liberty and
religiosity this country is unique and
we're blowing it and that's I'm going
crazy over that this is the last best
hope of man Lincoln was right and it's
being blown and and you know where it
started this is the irony of ironies
because they didn't give phd's in
America so in the late 19th century
scholars in America went to Germany of
all places to get their PhDs and there's
a basic rule in life Germany is always
wrong it's it's I'm sorry to say because
I have such close German friends and
that I'm music but I'm sorry is that low
yes I act I end my essay but never on
Germany it's on the internet but thank
you for bas exactly that's exactly right
I mean but even Merkel I mean she she's
blew it she just blew it I think it so
they these are the Bismarck gave us
socialism not Marx and Marx was German
too but but anyway this so these people
get their PhDs in in the socialist
universe this atheist universe of the
German University come back to America
and the rest is history so let's talk a
little bit about you know that the
modern political tenor there are a lot
of people who complain right now that
morality and politics seems to be
completely foreign to one another and I
have a lot of sympathies toward sort of
that position not in terms of the the
positions being espoused because
obviously you and I think agree on 99.9
percent of all things political but with
regard to sort of the the way the
politics is being carried on whether
it's people costing each other in
restaurants and screaming at them or
whether it is some of the president's
tweets
there's there's a feeling that morality
has sort of gone by the wayside how much
of biblical values and morality is
character and how much of it is public
policy when it comes to and when it
comes to politics because this was a big
argument obviously in 2016 it'll be a
big argument again I assume this is all
right so this'll blow your mind
I raised my boys to believe that
character was more important than
anything I'm one of the few Jewish
parents who didn't give a damn about my
kids grades I mean didn't give a damn I
I couldn't care less all I wanted was
good kids because I really do believe
character uber alles that character
ultimately will determine their lives
and whether they go to this college or
that college or no college is secondary
to the their character and having said
that I don't really care about Donald
Trump sins so it sounds like a
contradiction this is the most important
value I thought to my kids and then the
President of the United States I'm
saying it's secondary and that's but I
live with that I live with that
conjunction and ironically part of it is
that I got a lot of my wisdom if I have
any from the Bible God uses King David
who makes let I mean Donald Trump look
look safely I mean Donald Trump didn't
have any husband killed so he could
sleep with the wife let's be honest
King David did and and then God chooses
who does God choose of all the
Canaanites who does God choose to be the
one to help the Israelites get into
Canaan a prostitute it's almost the
Bible's in God's Way of saying listen I
could take these sexual sinners and I
could use them for good and I emphasize
the word sexual sin because I think that
a lot of religious people place too much
emphasis on sexual sin beyond all the
other areas of life I think that's a
problematic issue weren't worthy another
hour one day but but it's a it's a big
it's a big deal anyway
I so I care more about America than I
care about the character of a president
okay so let me let me give you the
counter-argument so the counter-argument
is not that the policy that the
president espouses doesn't matter
because obviously I'm very happy with a
lot of president Trump's policies I
think the country is winning because of
a lot of president Trump's policies but
there are externalities to public
character meaning that you're right I
don't care all that much about Donald
Trump's peccadilloes in the past because
whatever it doesn't affect the public
discourse I think in any serious way but
when the president says things that are
vile about people publicly or when the
president says that you know if people
come to his protest and they make
trouble you know punch them in the face
or whatever it is
when this sort of stuff happens it from
from a character perspective not only
does it have a problem create a problem
I think for the country it also creates
a problem for a lot of Christians who
are tempted to start saying King David
instead of just saying being Nathan
saying like right that's wrong you're
not allowed to do that like it's
tempting to play God in the King David
story and say right he's King David as
opposed to well God gets to pick who
King David is it's our job to say right
you're not allowed to take that guy's
husband and said that woman's husband
said mouths the battlefield to get
killed so that we can repent right so I
think that what's happened one of the
things that I think is driving apart the
country is it's not a referendum on on
the president so much as it's a
referendum on evangelical Christians and
religious Jews and people who are
overlooking at least publicly some of
the president's sins in order to
maintain a level of I think emotional
support because I think you can
intellectually support what the
president's on policy and still say
Rebbie Jackson the schmuck right here
and and it's that it's that gap that I
think is really driving away young
people particularly with regard to
President Trump well I I don't want it
to be driven away i i mean i'm i am you
know this is when you said we agree on
99.9 percent this might be the point one
where we have a difference
i I admire the religious community for
sticking with Donald Trump I have
defended them in writing a great deal
whether it's whether it's religious
Christians or Jews because they
understand what's at play here the the
fate of the United States of America the
last best hope of humanity is is at risk
here I'm not saying they shouldn't vote
for him
mind you I'm not saying they should it's
so fine so look when he sins should they
should they say that was bad what he
just did yes that's fine but but it and
and many do but they they try to keep a
perspective and this is where I know I
am NOT for saying this I believe there's
a civil war in the United States there
is no joy in my saying this I've said
this for years now I pray that it
remains nonviolent I don't know if it
will I think there's a lot of people on
the Left who if they could get away with
it would hurt physically hurt people on
the right and more so than the other way
around as Alan Dershowitz Hillary
Clinton
port a lifelong Democrat lifelong
liberal said to me and it is on it's on
video in his apartment in Manhattan last
year he said let me tell you something
as a Jew as an American as a liberal I
don't fear a handful of Nazis they mean
nothing I fear the far left and that's
how I feel and and the far left is
taking out Nazis and not taking over the
Republican Party that's an absurdity
it's it's a libel it's stupid but the
far left is taking over their Democratic
Party so there's a civil war and I am
NOT going to spend my time criticizing
the only guy who has saved me from
losing the country because there been
any other Republican and by the way I
was against him I was and it's all in
print I was against him during the
entire primary I said I but I said from
my first article if he wins the the
nomination I'll support him because
there's no choice but that there is
there is such a war at stake right now
nobody else would have defeated Hillary
Clinton he was the only one I believe
I don't think Ted Cruz would have I
don't think Marco Rubio would have I
don't believe Jeb Bush would have and
and that was the brink Supreme Court
wise values wise you name it that was
the brink for this country so in light
of that a moronic tweet or at or an
awful statement is is is very small the
question is my bigger issue I guess the
question is why does that always have to
be contextualized meaning I think I can
agree with I can agree with virtually
every word she just said they're right
but the question that I have is that the
next the next election the biggest
single voting block is going to be
Millennials it's going to be younger
people and those people actually take
his tweet seriously they actually when
when he does something that when he says
something they find bio that actually
matters to them even more so than the
policy in many cases and what matters
even more than that is is I think so
many people on the right who seem to
refuse to acknowledge I just don't see
why you can't do both I don't see why
you can't say his policies are great I'm
thrilled with his policies and I wish
you would stop doing that or it would be
better if you'd stop doing that or what
he just said was on our veg and be
better off as a country he hadn't done
that but that doesn't mean I'm going to
turn over
country to this bunch outside if you but
you've just contextualized it and that's
great if you put that in that concept
they listen I can't stand what he just
said but frankly the policies are saving
the country
no there isn't anybody who supports him
who would differ with you right the only
the only problem is that by saying but
what is the the point of the
contextualisation I mean
contextualization to you and to the
audience you can make the transition Roy
problem is that if let's say he says
something about Charlottesville and it's
something that I want we may have a
difference of understanding and I have
perused this a tremendous number of
times he didn't say they were good Nazis
and-and-and he said there are good
people on both side a night on the
Friday night wasn't that about statues
the Friday night was he White's okay do
you think he was saying that there were
good Nazis do you believe he's saying
there were no to you for marching not
the Nazis I think what he was saying is
that they were marching with it now
here's my here's my schedule against
that he didn't say that okay because he
doesn't believe there's good anti far
known I think that I think the easy way
for him to say things is there's good
people on both sides right but he
doesn't believe there's any good and I'm
not sure that he thinks things through
it's the extent necessary okay whether
he does or does the point is not
Charlottesville and I'm happy now are
you Charlotte so he can go back through
the text and we'll bring out our Tamil
and we can actually look look through
the legislative history of what he said
but any anything that he said that
people find distasteful particularly or
that you would find distasteful in any
other context why can't we just say
that's distasteful so for here's a good
example he just went and he met with kim
jeong-hoon he was extraordinarily warm
toward kim jeong-hoon he said really
nice things about a guy who was a
dictator of 25 million people or so he's
one of the worst people on planet earth
right and the President of the United
States said he's a strong guy running
one in 10,000 people could do this sort
of thing right and as somebody who
studied the former Soviet Union you I'm
sure you look at this and you go well a
hold up a second here Ron so why can't
we just say that and then when it comes
time for 2020 say right and the overall
opinion is I'll vote for him anyway
because that's that but not every day is
a referendum on the election this is
this I guess is my my main point of
criticism because you and I are probably
gonna vote the same way in 2020 right
the chances are very good that I vote
for president or or this year right in
2020 in 2018 we'll certainly both the
same right I'm going to vote Republican
in 28 yes in 2020 there's a very high
likelihood I'll vote for president Trump
barring some sort of cataclysmic event
right okay all of that said I do think
that there is something deeply important
about conservatives pointing out when he
does something wrong because otherwise
we lose our intellectual credibility and
learn as though it is our job to become
his lawyers as opposed to being
advocates for a position for which he is
not I understand that and it makes sense
you and I both speak a great deal to
young people I through Prager you and
you through of course the daily wire and
all of your and your podcasts and all of
the things you do I I have a big
following you have a big following I
don't think they're thinking gee this
Prager who talks about morality he
doesn't have that much credibility with
me cuz he supports the president because
people understand why I do when I try to
make it clear why I do so your worry is
not my worry but but we need you and I'm
it's not you're the last person I would
patronize of the six billion people on
earth assembly so I'm not patronizing
you we need you terribly remember though
that there are people on our side who
don't there is one I don't want to say
his name because I know him pretty well
oh and it'll be obvious if anybody wants
to research it but but most people won't
who said who said that who's a lifelong
Republican and said Trump is Trump is
worse than Stalin I mean I mean okay it
is at idiotic and and and and it's and
it's very destructive and there are
those who you know they they've left the
party George will I adore George will
he's done preview university videos and
and he's left the Republican Party these
this is overwrought reaction the world
is dirty and and I we had a Donald Trump
with with tremendous style and and all
the wonderful things you would like but
we have him it's sort of like a marriage
he's a package Trump is a package this
package saved this country from the left
taking it over in the last election that
is so big that I somehow never lose
picture of that it with his the sins
that he commits that's my position your
position is for our credibility let's
point out each of the sins that he
commits fine we need you and we need me
and I mean this quite sincerely and
you're yours is as as morality based as
- morality based but my my I am so
focused on the near death of America
that took place in 2016
and I believe that I believe had Hillary
Clinton or any Democrat I don't get a
job I mean it's irrelevant had any
Democrat won then I had no reason to
have faith that this country will not go
the way of Western Europe well it's it's
always great to have you here and I want
to I want to part with with one question
for you dennis prager author of the
rational Bibles so if you are going to
pick your favorite section of of the
Torah well what is your what is your
favorite section of the torus this is
just a fun and a parting question you
that that's it's like what's you know
what's my favorite part about my wife
that's how much I love the Torah and I'm
sorry that dangerous here yeah no I
understand I'm crazy about the Ten
Commandments I I am and I spend a vast
amount of time in this the book that's
out the first one on Exodus explaining
why they alone they alone in fact do not
steal alone would make a good world and
IIIi would I guess I would that's why I
began with Exodus because I'm in love
with the Ten Commandments and and
they're so including honor your father
and mother which changed my life and I
am I hope my kids follow it - okay well
Dennis it's great to have you here and
obviously Dennis Internet your volume
comes out next year his his book on
Genesis comes out next year can't wait
for the rest of them to unfold Dennis
thanks so much for stopping by
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carr Amina hair and makeup
is by Jessica Oliveira and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright board publishing 2018
[Music]